[Music]
I never would think like just by
releasing some music and posting videos
I could have this much of a strong of a
connection between so many people six
seconds is all it took for Shawn Mendes
to become a star the Pickering Ontario
native was signed to an international
record deal soon after his vine videos
went viral in 2014 I was a little
stressed out us down a little because I
feel like I'm sort of in that sort of
fanbase of like almost like the Austin
Mahone Justin Bieber my music's a little
bit different than their so I'm a little
worried people aren't gonna react to it
his debut single life of the party
rocketed to the top of the iTunes charts
in both Canada and the US just 90
minutes after its release when the song
was up they're like number one and like
with all these other artists who are
massive who I look up to and I have
looked over to for years it's like such
a weird feeling but Shawn didn't let the
overnight success go to his head
sometimes you look at celebrities and
you feel like they're on like a higher
level than you and you almost feel like
they're like untouchable type of thing I
don't no matter how many followers you
have like it shouldn't be like scared to
tweet like I have so much acting today
like it's really bothering me type of
thing just reminds people that I'm just
a regular human and it's battle Fitness
with fans that's helped land Sean on
Times list of most influential teens for
four years straight I mean I really
couldn't believe it especially if he
went on the list and saw these people I
was up there with so it was really
really cool one girl got Maya my lyrics
from life-of-the-party tattooed on her
she got my attention
that doesn't mean go tattoo yourself
with lyrics that's not what I'm saying
that's not a saying I was getting out I
see all of you
when
when you said they wouldn't listen in
April of 2015 Sean released handwritten
and made history becoming the youngest
artist since Justin Bieber to score
number-one album we're working on
something all you hope for is for it to
be successful and then when it came out
and went number one it was just like a
really really heartwarming feeling
[Music]
realizing that your music is affecting
people and whatever that helps them
through a breakup or a rough time in
their life is the best thing just over a
year later the superstars scored his
second number-one album on the Billboard
charts with aluminate I never want to
hide from actually what is going on in
my life with my music so what I'm
writing about you know and illuminate is
truthfully what's happening in my life
[Music]
since day one you know like my fans and
I have been very close in age so you
know as as I'm getting you know 218 and
growing up they they are also and so
it's nothing is becoming less relatable
and that included speculation regarding
Sean's sexuality which he handled in the
most mature way possible conquering the
rumors head-on first of all I'm not gay
second of all it shouldn't make a
difference if it was or if I wasn't the
focus would be on the music not my
sexuality I just think like in this day
and age like just like immaturity and
ignorance it's just so high it was less
about my feelings being hurt being hurt
and more about me just being frustrated
with the immaturity of my generation and
that's kind of just what I wanted to get
across with Sean's third studio album he
pushed the conversation forward once
again inspired by producer and
songwriter Teddy Geiger coming out as
transgender Sean decided to make music
that was more inclusive while she was
going through one of the biggest things
the biggest thing to ever happen in her
life I was also making the biggest album
in my life and so together we had this
super kinetic emotional time you know
and I think I owe a lot of being able to
dig deep into myself to Teddy because I
was watching her go through this really
big change and kind of you know how that
was now at the age of 21 sean has scored
his first ever number-one single on the
Billboard Hot 100 with his girlfriend
Camilla kebaya she
[Music]
and tomorrow Shawn will hit another
milestone as he plays the biggest solo
show of his career over 50,000 fans in
his hometown of Toronto you know you've
got like a little economy going if I
Shawn Mendes Inc yeah yeah I realize
that even if you are the boss the whole
point is that there's a synergy you know
to make things work because if it
doesn't work for me it doesn't work for
anyone
[Music]